resuelve para allí y verifica tu
solución 20 menos 7 y es igual a 66 lo
que voy a hacer es llevarlas a un solo
lado y si nos encontramos con un
coeficiente que esté multiplicando la
podemos dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre ese coeficiente las íes
las podemos agrupar del lado derecho o
del lado izquierdo de la ecuación de
hecho voy a hacer ambos casos para
empezar me parece que es más fácil
agrupar leyes del lado derecho y te lo
voy a mostrar en un momento así es que
si quiero agrupar las 10 del lado
derecho como puedo eliminar las del lado
izquierdo así es que si del lado
izquierdo tengo menos 7 y 7 y en
negativo podemos sumar 7 y a ambos lados
de la ecuación sumamos 7 y ambos lados
de la ecuación y que nos da del lado
izquierdo tenemos 20 menos 7 y 7 y 7-6 7
y se cancelan y nos queda tan solo 20 y
del lado derecho que tengo 6 y 7 y que
es igual a 13 y
-6 ya tenemos las 10 del lado derecho
ahora para deshacernos de este menos 6
que tenemos
necesito sumar más 6 a ambos lados de la
ecuación sumamos más 6 del lado derecho
y sumamos más 6 del lado izquierdo
que nos da del lado izquierdo 13 y 66
nos queda tan solo 13 y menos 66 se
cancelan y 20 más 6 del lado derecho nos
queda 26 esto es igual a 13 y ahora aquí
tenemos 13 x y si quiero despejar la aie
lo que tengo que hacer es dividir entre
13 o multiplicar por 13 ya no así es que
vamos a dividir entre 13 a ambos lados
de la ecuación dividimos entre 13 del
lado izquierdo y dividimos entre 13 del
lado derecho que nos resulta 13 y entre
13 nos da simplemente y los 13 se
simplifican y del lado izquierdo nos
queda 26 entre 13 2 hemos obtenido la
solución ya igualados
ahora regresemos porque mencioné que era
más fácil agrupar las 'íes' del lado
derecho pues porque de esa manera obtuve
en coeficiente positivo el lado derecho
13 y sin embargo si hubiera restado
menos 6 a ambos lados de la ecuación del
lado izquierdo hubiera obtenido menos
que también es válido déjame mostrarte
lo que escribamos la ecuación 20 no lo
voy a hacer con otro color lo voy a
hacer en turquesa 20 menos 7 y es igual
a 6 menos 6
ahora vamos a restar y ambos lados de la
ecuación 66 james 6 y que nos queda del
lado izquierdo
nos queda 20 menos 13 y esto es igual a
6 james 6 se cancela y nos queda tan
sólo menos 6 ahora ya tenemos las 36 del
lado izquierdo necesitamos deshacernos
de ese 20 para lo cual vamos a restar 20
a ambos lados de la ecuación
y ahora esto se cancela por eso hicimos
eso nos queda menos 13 y es igual a
menos 26 ahora dividimos entre menos 13
dividimos entre menos 13 a ambos lados
de la ecuación dividimos entre menos 13
y tenemos aquí del lado izquierdo menos
13 por algo entre menos 13 nos da ese
algo esos menos 3 se cancelan nos queda
simplemente y que es igual a menos 26
entre menos 13 2 aquí agrupe las 10 del
lado izquierdo mientras que aquí agrupe
las 'íes' del lado derecho y ese primero
el lado derecho para que todo quedara
positivo pero lo que hicimos aquí
también es perfectamente válido ahora lo
último que voy a hacer es asegurarnos
que obtuvimos la respuesta correcta
podemos estar tranquilos pues obtuvimos
la misma respuesta de las dos maneras
pero vamos a verificar sustituyamos ya
igualados en la ecuación para verificar
que se obtiene una identidad tenemos 20
menos 7 por 100 que es 2 esto es igual a
6 por 2
-6 del lado izquierdo tenemos 20 menos 7
por 2 recuerda que la multiplicación se
hace primero 20 menos 14 esto es igual a
6 por 2 12 menos 620 menos 14 es igual a
6 12 menos seis es igual a 6 6 es igual
a 6 así es que nuestra respuesta es
correcta